[Applause]
let's address the elephant in the room
obviously this is tuesday you guys are
all listening to this
tuesday morning okay we had to get this
[ __ ] up bright and early because
um we don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen tonight we don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen tomorrow we don't
know if it's gonna be a
uh another four years of trump we don't
know if it's gonna be undecided still
for another week we don't know if
there's gonna be riots in the streets
we don't know what the [ __ ] going on
and
uh if you asked me last week or two
weeks ago what i thought would happen
this
election i would say man it looks like
the momentum is kind of on biden's side
all the polls are saying biden
everything seems to be pushing towards
buying it maybe biden got it
the last two weeks
trump supporters have
gone wild bro i mean
the momentum behind trump objectively
speaking
is unreal i don't remember this first
election no
not even close no i mean seeing
the new york trumpers shut down of
arizona
that makes sense because it's staten
island i assume everybody in staten
island is
is a trump family 100 fair right but
still
they shut down the whole bridge happened
jersey too jersey's always a blue state
i'm pretty sure
right jersey they're going where they
getting these flags
amazon got these flag can anybody get a
fight everybody got these flags big ass
flags huge flags
i'll i'll say this people who support
trump probably love flags
so they probably been had that [ __ ] yeah
flag loving folks if we like you we got
your flag
yeah i feel you i feel like the second
biden one they put that right
i mean the trump won they put that next
to the american flag and they're like
they just had it up i've just never seen
a trump flag until the last maybe
maybe those boats the boat parade going
around yeah remember that then i started
to see those flags everywhere
they a few cars apparently followed some
bus and like surrounded this like
biden bus in texas yeah which
on one side looks super illegal but the
other side is super
lit yeah if that's your guy yeah
i mean come on bro you bully the butt
who's on the bus do we know
they think maybe wendy davis but she's
nobody she's the ashley
a former senator lady nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you
uh they probably thought it was somebody
on that bus
though they don't care huh they don't
care i mean they hope for somebody on
but they don't care yeah i mean
they didn't even have secret service or
whatever protecting the bus so there was
nobody of importance on the bus they
didn't have a cop car that means wendy
davis could get
murked nobody would give a flying [ __ ]
you had her in a red state in a biden
kamala bus
they didn't even put a police car behind
her they wanted her dead
they were trying to get her the [ __ ] out
of here who's wendy davis
who is wendy that's a good question but
anyway they had her shook they were
calling 911 which
is [ __ ] imagine that
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
supposed to do you want a bus what do
you think they're gonna do shoot it
yeah i don't run it off the road i don't
know
maybe that's why lil wayne voted trump
he was like i remember that bus
situation i'm not [ __ ] around
no more we're getting shot up or fired
with a bus i want my guns
yeah see what happens when you don't
have guns see you could have had guns on
that bus
but now you voted against your guns see
see what happens
trump served time for a gun possession
charge i wouldn't be surprised if you
voted
i mean yeah wait what no trump's not
[ __ ]
immediately he's gonna vote for him that
immediately switches the vote
before he went to prison that's my guy
guns so uh
all these all these uh what's it called
he's been doing i don't even know what
to call them i end up calling them shows
performances what are they called
concert concerts rally
they're called a rally but the [ __ ]
thing looks like a concert yeah okay
it's a performance it's unbelievable the
momentum is unbelievable and you're
seeing more and more people come out
more and more people that are like of
the culture come out like seeing the
nelk boys
who are canadian yeah which is hilarious
right it's like they can't even vote but
he's like not put him front row
this will influence some people get them
out there they were out there
who else little pump yeah out of nowhere
start supporting
yeah is all over it jorge
moz would all been on it but now he's
doing like crowder yeah like he's going
on all these like conservative podcasts
when he came to miami like that's right
and he's posting about it he's about
that's the nice thing about being a
fighter is no one could really talk [ __ ]
yeah like he's like i'm for pro trump
and they're like we'll bully someone
else
you got that yeah that's funny they're
all over tommy larrant
like you dumb [ __ ] and then mozzarella
was like nah but i like them they're
like
that stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] tommy
so it you're seeing all this momentum in
that direction
and my buddy was doing calls for biden
you know you can like
call random people right and he said an
interesting thing
what your buddies man lame for what
what are your buddies just so [ __ ]
late who doesn't yeah
that's kind of lame [ __ ] yeah
granny's like a social like a services
counselor at school what is that [ __ ]
called like the school therapist how you
feeling now looking down
still lame spot i made them labor
no no i'm just saying like they're not
doing anything now they're not in the
school
they barely did anything in the school
so it is free time let me
call you his free time he's like let me
call for buying something he's calling
people being like hey are you voting
no he's a nerd right yeah yeah he's lame
he's lame he's a [ __ ] leg
so uh so basically this [ __ ] loser
my great friend is a piece of [ __ ] so
he's calling people
i'm his only friend he said an
interesting thing he's like the people
that you call that i guess are trump
voters i don't know how they can tell
who's going to vote for who maybe they
have like pass election results also
registration registration oh
registration yeah interesting
they don't say who they're voting for
even on the phone
and the biden ones always say about it i
kind of always thought that
so the numbers you get in polling
are inaccurate and i don't know if they
show undecided numbers in
polling but if they did i would just
take a big chunk of those undecideds and
i would throw them in the trump
direction and see how the numbers then
added up and because i think that
there is a huge like public cost for
saying that you're a trump supporter
yeah i don't know if there's a big
public cause for saying you're abiding
supporter
like maybe you're like your conservative
friends think you're a [ __ ] or they
think you're a [ __ ] or they think
almost zero
but there's no public cost you're fine
like you're not going to be accosted for
walking around with a biden thing you'll
be followed in a bus
have we heard of any stories of like a
trump fan just like
like just beating up someone because
they had a biden hat with zero
antagonism no like
rally no i've seen like signs get
vandalized size available but you
haven't
gotta get ripped down you haven't seen
us something like someone's at a diner
we saw that thing where like someone's
at a diner he had like a mega hat on and
somebody just like throws a [ __ ]
milkshake out of him yeah
right you don't just see that out of
nowhere yeah not right it's a little
it's like
wearing a mega hat is kind of wearing
like a red bandana as part of your
outfit
like if you go in the wrong neighborhood
yeah you would get [ __ ] up
yeah you know what i'm saying mm-hmm
wearing a mag ahead is this like a gang
wrestling yeah
i got you yeah yeah i also wear those
bro
well i'm gonna come from texas if you
were in a biden shirt actually there's
definitely places where it's like like i
told my parents you gotta whoever you
gotta vote early
don't be out in the [ __ ] polls in
texas on election day being brown with a
bunch of trump supporters
so like i feel when you're saying
they're gangs i'm like i think it's also
dangerous to be a biden supporter in
trump
trump town but have we seen any examples
of that as what i
was uh was asking i haven't seen
examples of trump supporters getting
[ __ ] up either
oh no yeah tons like there's always like
viral things going around
like they'll just be like randomly have
the maga hat on it gets ripped off at
school
it gets ripped off in this diner there
was one there was like a bunch of these
things going around maybe the guy's just
violating dress code because you're not
allowed to have hats in school you know
i mean
noticeable like it's like such a
statement whereas like it's a bold
biden hat i think is not as noticeable
it's not as antagonistic
yeah yeah and also like what a hat looks
like the association with the biden
hat is not as polarizing as association
with the mag
right the association with the maga hat
that carries all the worst
parts of uh trump's campaign right so
like
the worst assumption the worst person
that supports trump you're going to put
that on a mega hat
even if that's not who they think that's
what we do the worst assumption of biden
is
is what he's like too liberal
or he's seen that like you're not
punching somebody for that he's your
grandpa
exactly no but just to akash's point
like i heard some news article about
the retirement homes in florida they if
you're
a biden supporter like you stop getting
invited to the golf games and [ __ ] like
that
which i guess giving you [ __ ] and [ __ ]
like that i could see you getting
ostracized from your community
yeah yeah 100 especially in the south
right but i don't see
physical acts of violence that's what
that's what i'm saying like
when i'm thinking about this election
like what's gonna happen i'm like
if biden wins i don't think there's
riots
if trump wins i don't think there's
riots
i do think there's looting by the people
who are playing to loot no matter what
like i think there's people right now
who are like i need some new versace i
need some new gucci i need some new [ __ ]
and i'm breaking down the [ __ ] store
to get it no matter what
but and this is an excuse and those are
the same people in the past
looted because of what happened they
took advantage of the moment they
enriched themselves off the moment they
weren't doing because they're angry
nobody's angry at police brutality and
they're like i need some fendi to make
up for this [ __ ]
you know what i mean i can see those
groups doing it regardless of who wins
because they just they're selfish yeah
yeah they're just trying to enrich
themselves
anybody like yelling in the streets like
yes it's my time
i think either way there's going to be
some [ __ ] going down whoever wins it's
just going to be really i think it's
just going to vary by region i think if
trump wins
new york liberal havens are going to
riot and loot and if
biden wins i don't know if there will be
riot and looting necessarily but there
will be some there will be some [ __ ]